- Do you struggle with taking notes
in an effective way at work?
In this video, I'm going to
share the note taking technique
that I developed over
the six years of working
at the consulting firm, McKinsey.
I do believe that note
taking in an effective way
can really make the difference
for you and your career.
So please watch until the end
for the tips that I have to
share here today with you
from all the experiences that I have
of really conducting literally
hundreds of interviews
with the clients and
internal and external experts
over the time of my career.
So welcome everyone to
another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning
and as you may be see
I got myself some nice consulting merch.
So please fix a nice Excel cup.
If you are interested to
get this stuff as well
check out the merch of Crazy
Management Consultants.
Maybe you've seen my
video about two weeks ago
on Crazy Management Consultant memes
they're so hilarious,
so I thought that I'd just
get some merch as well.
I will leave a link to their website below
in the video description so check it out.
But guys, let's now
talk about note taking.
And I wanna start by
sharing a little story
that really happened to me
when I was a young consultant at work,
we had a project where we
needed to help a client
optimize its working capital.
So pretty much optimize its inventory,
accounts receivables
and accounts payables.
Now we needed to conduct an interview
with the head of one of the
business units of the company
to sit together with them
and collect some ideas
and share some thoughts
on what could be done
in that the business unit
to really improve the
working capital situation.
So I walked into the meeting
and probably this was in my
first year of being a consultant
and I was accompanied by
a more senior associate
with whom we together
conducted the interview.
It was a good and long
conversation going on
for almost two hours.
And I still remember my blog,
I had pages over pages of notes
that I had written down there
just trying to capture everything
pretty much of importance
that was being said.
So we had this is good conversation.
And I remember that we walked
back into the team room
and there of course our
project lead was sitting
and he was looking at us and asking,
so, hey how did it went?
What did we learn?
So he looked at me and I
tried to give an answer
but I was so puzzled,
and I tried to look through my notes
you know, to really come up
with the most important points
of what was discussed,
because in my mind there
was just so much being said,
so many information that I put down
that it was really
difficult for me now to,
on the spot really share the top ideas,
the top points that we shared.
So seeing how much I struggled
the senior associate was jumping
in and try to help me out.
And he just looked at his notes
and said something like,
so yes, we had a good conversation.
And there were five great ideas
that we can now implement really
to improve the working capital.
One, two, three, four, five,
and then to each point
he was briefly describing
what the idea was.
And after seeing this, how we handled that
I was just so astonished how he did this
because clearly he did
something completely different
in the that he took us notes
in the way that he
organized the information
while conducting the interview.
That now enabled him to communicate
in this very effective way.
So later I was just sitting with him
and we had a good relationship,
so I just asked him,
hey can you just show
me what you did there?
How did you come up with that?
How are you taking your notes?
So then he showed me his system
and this is pretty much now the system
that I also took over and
refined a bit over time.
And this is the system
that I will show you now in this video.
But before I talk about
this approach in detail
let me give you the top three reasons
why taking notes in consulting
and probably also many other
professional jobs as well
is very important.
Let me also share what
is specific about that.
So first point is the
special circumstances
that you are facing when
you take these notes.
So I did some research
before I did this video
so I looked how other
how-to-take-notes videos
on YouTube look like
and many of them are about
how you can take these
beautifully looking,
super well structured notes,
while I trust that this can be great
and effective as well as passionately
for studying or for taking
notes during university,
this just does not work in consulting
and indeed probably
in most other professional
contexts as way.
And the reason is that you are
under a lot of time pressure.
So you're sitting in these meetings
and often your interview partner
the person that you talk
to will talk pretty fast
and you cannot just constantly
ask him to slow down
because you need to
write it more precisely,
you know, you want to call her your notes
or anything like that, right?
This just will not work.
And also after the meeting,
you will regularly not have the time
to go over all your notes in details
and try to rewrite them
or make them look good.
Just check out my video
on how a typical work week
of the day of a consultant looks like.
Again I will link it somewhere above,
if you see that at first you'll understand
why consultants really not have time
to now detail rewrite all of them.
So bottom line is you need a system
where you can take notes efficiently
you do not have the time
to make them look great.
Second, there's a special
expectation in consulting
that especially as a junior
you pretty much take notes
all the time, always.
Also, if it's about topics
that do not directly
relate to your work stream
to your specific module,
to your responsibilities.
So very often you will be in a situation
where maybe a client
walks into the team room
and is having a conversation
with the project lead.
And then the client talks
about different things
and of course the project lead
tries to engage with
them as much as possible.
And then very often you will
find yourself in a situation
where when the client left
the project lead will look to you and say,
Hey, Heinrich you took notes
of everything he said, right?
And then you are like sitting there.
Maybe you even feel like
that wasn't even about my work stream,
why should I have taken notes about that?
So for instance, also a team call
where a partner talks about
something, doing something
maybe you believe that probably
it's not going to be you
who will actually implement it.
But what if maybe at the end of the call
or maybe later in a team meeting,
the project lead asks you if you can do
that specific piece of work
that now the partner talked about earlier
and now you will look pretty bad
if you pretty much just have to say,
okay but I didn't take notes.
Can we please go over it again?
What exactly I should do?
So again, situations like
this come up all the time.
So pretty much a good advice
for young consultants is
whenever information of
significance are being shared
by partners, by your
project lead or by clients
doesn't matter whether
they're directly related
to your work stream or not
always take notes.
And the third thing that is special
about taking notes in consulting
is that often, especially
in client meetings
you will try to really take
the notes with pen and paper
but not just with a laptop.
So I know there are these
great note taking programs
like OneNote or Evernote,
I use them myself or other
applications as well.
But especially in consulting,
when you sit in front of a client,
if you have a laptop in front of you
and are typing down
every word that he says
often this will create
a big perceived barrier
between you and the client.
It will also often make
the whole situation
much more formal than it is.
Maybe the client we closed down,
shut down a little bit
and will not talk that openly with you
because it feels like
every word that he says
is now taken down on a protocol.
So for these reasons,
it is a common point
in these coinciding onboarding trainings
and also the general way of working
that you will try to take
notes, pen and paper.
This will often help you to
communicate with your client
in a much better way.
And for this reason, of course,
you need to have a system
that also enables you
to take the notes in
a pen and paper format
and not only on a computer.
And now let's get tangible.
How do I do it?
What is this note taking system
that I really refined and also
implemented in my daily job?
And I prepared here a sheet of paper
that really shows this.
So I hope now that auto focus switches.
So you see that there
are different sections
on this piece of paper.
So I try to, not only just make
a long list of bullet points
but really organize the information.
Now because I know that's
probably pretty hard to follow
just based on this,
let me now sketch it for you,
how exactly it looks like.
I will use my PC for that.
So let's now go over our format
how exactly this could look like.
So this is now a big piece of paper.
And as you see now, how you often start
by putting the date when
the meeting took place
in the top left,
then I often also like to put the title,
so what was it about?
And then I also like to include a list
of all the participants.
This is also important whenever
when you write meeting minutes
or any type of protocol after the meeting
that it's often good practice
to also write it down
who was part of the meeting.
So make sure that your
list everybody down.
Then a little thing that I
really found useful for myself,
it's not necessarily something
that I've seen other people do.
But what I really found useful
is to insert a little drawing of the table
and then write the initials
of who was sitting where,
and for me, this really helped
especially in the beginning of a project
where you have lots of different meetings
and can easily get to know lots of people
in a very short amount of time.
For me, it was always difficult
after a couple of days
to really remembering.
So who was who just based on the names
but now with these little sketches,
these really helped me to get
a bit of a visual
representation of the table
then back into my mind,
the knowing okay, Mr. So-and-so
was the guy who was sitting
at the end of the table
in this specific meeting.
So this is just a little
mind tag that I use
to just help me really
remembering who was who.
So then you see the
upper half of the paper,
this is now kind of the general area.
The general note taking
area where just write
kind of general remarks
of what was being said.
So this is the part that
now most closely resembles
this general old school style
of just taking notes, one
point after the other.
And of course, if you do run out of space
you're gonna, would just
take a second piece of paper
at some point is actually
just to continue writing down
these bullets as you see here.
Now, the more interesting
part is here, the lower part,
and on the very bottom quarter of the page
I often use two sections.
So to-dos for me, to-dos
this for the firm,
so for our consulting firm,
and then to-dos for the client.
So in the conversation,
whenever something was coming up
where either myself or
later as a project lead,
me and or my team needs to do something,
I will directly write it down here,
not in the upper part
but then also whenever there was something
where the client confirmed
and committed to do something
I would also write it down here.
And this was always great
because in the end of the meeting
then you can do something
really powerful and say,
okay now let me just recap,
what are the next steps,
and then you can talk
about what you will do now
but then you can also talk about
what the client will do now.
Because otherwise in a long meeting
you often have the situation
that in-between you say,
okay this is something that you can do
and then maybe the client agrees,
but in the very end probably
both of you have forgotten.
And if we will have them
pages of notes written out,
it can be quite tough to
really find these to-do points.
It's really helpful to
have them in one place
because then you can recap in the end
and you can again ask the client
to commit to these to-dos.
And then of course also maybe afterwards
you wanna write short meeting minutes
and then you already
have this list of, to-dos
and you do not need to search them
among pages of pages of notes.
They are just hidden in the
middle of lots of other texts.
Now, next here in the
middle part of the page
you see an area where
you can really take lots of value
in the situations that I was describing
in the story earlier.
And this requires a
little bit of preparation
before you walk into the meeting
and this preparation is asking yourself
what you actually wanna
get out of the interview.
And this is indeed also a mistake
that some more junior consultants do
they just walk into these client meetings,
they walk into these interviews.
And they're just having
a general discussion
about a topic with a client
but without a clear goal in mind,
what is your objective?
What do you wanna take
out of the conversation?
Now, coming back to the example
of the working capital reduction project.
So what do you want to be looking for
from these meeting as a
list of tangible ideas
that now you hope that the
client will share with you
of what could be done to improve
the working capital of a company.
And so indeed if you know
before the meeting that this
is what you're looking out for
try to make a section
that whenever the client says something
that could be used as an idea,
that could be used as a
lever in this direction
where you directly write it down.
Because this now is really powerful
whenever afterwards, somebody asks you,
well what are you actually
taking out of this conversation?
You can list exactly these
reasons, these levers
these ideas that you
collected in the meeting.
So now that being said,
what do you use, the bigger part of front,
where here you write on all the things
that are neither to do
for you or the client,
and are also not directly applicable
to this main objective of
the meeting that you have
for instance, collecting
optimization ideas.
So this could be just other general points
of information that you
find worthwhile taking notes
that the client shares,
pretty much everything else
that somehow seems to be relevant
but you do not wanna add
into one of these other
buckets that we have below.
So trust me, if you
employ a system like this
for your specific situation as well,
it will be far more organized
than 99% of most people walking outside
and doing these kinds of interviews.
I hope this was indeed
helpful and valuable.
And as always, if you have
any questions on this topic
leave me a comment below
in the comment section
because you know that by leaving a comment
not only will I try to
help you as good as I can
but you are also helping me
because every comment looks
good to the YouTube algorithm.
In addition to that,
if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please smash the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel
to not miss the regular videos.
If you want to see even more from me
also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is Firmlearning
and I also have a mailing list.
You can find a signup link to that
below in the video description.
I now wanna say thank you
to all the members of, Firm Learning.
You are really making a great
contribution to the channel.
You're really supporting this work.
So thank you so much.
And if anybody of you contemplates
of becoming a member as well,
you can just hit the join button
next to the subscribe button
where you will learn about
all the details and yes
you will get access to
some member-only perks.
So check it out to see if
this might something that
might also interest you.
Now, let me add by
saying thank you so much
for everybody who watched until the end.
I very much appreciate that.
As you know, I release a video
on this channel every single Saturday.
So looking forward to next
week, to next Saturday
to talk about the next topic.
So until then, bye-bye
and good weekend to all of you.